τελικάνα κάνει κόμα τούτι συζήτηση ξεκίνησε ένυβασουμε εξεκίνησαμε ται με τοφιδία θα προσπαθήσουνα διοχι ετεύσω
του τις δύναμη σε κάποια η κανάτοπό που προσπαθώ να υρω να κατευούμε στες επόμενες
βουλευτικές εκλογές υπάρχει σχέσ με το φυδια μιλάτε τελευταία φορά που μιλήσαμε στεκάμα τώ να
λευτερομπήτο κίπα το φιδία μου πισταία πο λότο ότι είσε ωσιοπαθίς πρέπει να τον επήραξεντων
το πράγμα λέι τώρα πάμε βάλει με στον πρόεδριγόνο χριστό δουλίδες μαζί του εξιμήνες ένα
αλλάξον κύπρο δεν θα θενα να ξανα να κατωθώ με τες μάες με την κύρπρωτι
ότι δυστυχώς είναι βρομια και δυσοδίας ούμεέα θα που ι κανένας ποτέψεμας είμαι υθεντικός δούλεψ
πολλάς κληρα να καθαρισωτονοαμού και να έχο ένα τύπον όπως τούτο ο οποίος να μην
έρτει μετά που μ έκαμε τότανες ζηλίκια ι πει να στιγνώμι του ότι ανθρώπι να
ξέρεις χτίζουν καριέρες πας πάε σε προσωπικό ότιόλα αυτή ζωή ότα αυτά τα διώματα που
τιμουργήσαν πά πολλα ψύχολαγικά προβλήματα ιθα τια γνωστούμετα καετά διανοητικές για ταραχές εκίνησαν τα ζάρκα
τους τα άλογα και ότι έκτή σα ε δο χρόνια κάματα και ημά σου το
κρίο πραια πάτει θα τουρέ τον τεθερις φορές νέρας αραντερα σίχου πάνωτηλε χεφίλι άλλο ναντ
ναλλά εότκα σήμερα μαζί σας εδώ στο πλατό ένας καλεσμένος μια τον υπροσωπικό ήτα ο
γνοστός επιφηρμάτιας ο χριστόφορος τον ναί της ιστοφορέ καλός όρισε σε ευχαριστώ ποδεύτηκες την πρόσκληση
να τα βούμε να σεγαλά θεσένα μου είμαι έτοιμος να μιλήσουμε για ότι θέλεις λάριος
τερια όλα αρχικά να σε ωτήσω επειδή σε μάθαμε όλις εξέίρουν τα τελευταία χρόνια άλλά
να μας πίσκεση ποιος υνοχριστώφορος τον νάης όταν λες πιος είναιπχούμε πολλές κατηγορίες οικογενακά στη
δουριά στη ζωή